hey everyone davello here and in today's
video we're getting that good good I I
oh my Lord like these probably some of
the most overpowered techniques and
fattest info dumps revealed to us here
throughout this video that are super
integral to the overall outcome of this
overbearing Saga that is the killing
game and really just the entire story in
general so if you are Kane and want me
to keep pumping out content just like
this but for a variety of different
series then make sure to hit that
subscribe button and push this video to
5K likes so we all know that you want
the hisoka versus crolo beat down that
have begun scripting but anyway moving
forward into the 13th Arc of
gigahutami's Beast of a series that is
Jujutsu Kaizen so kicking things back
off we shoot over to Tokyo Colony number
one where Hannah could assume
mysteriously greets and Awakening Mega
me as my fated one still Dosey Mimi asks
how long he was out for with Yuji who's
looking like the maddest King ever
dropped out on a robe sipping on some
wine remarks that he'd been unconscious
for two entire days and now it's almost
the 15th of November having collected
some food himself takaba enters the room
and as Hannah settles on house with a
tub of ice cream the group began
discussing how it's quite odd that the
power is still on in Tokyo Megami
presumes that kinjaku may have colluded
with the higher ups to keep the power on
so it wouldn't interfere with the
cullingham itself and then goes off to
take a dump and because he was out of
the action for the last two days asked
to be filled in on what happened while
he was out let's explain that Yuji
bumped into zacaba and chose to join
forces in an attempt to locate Mega me
eventually takaba was able to locate
Hannah carrying megamik through the sky
and that's how they ended up all here
together bringing him fully up to date
Yuji shows migumi how many points both
Hikari and Yuta have telling him that
including his own enter Carver's points
they've met their quota now all that's
left is to figure out how many points
are needed to actually leave the god
temp culling game here at his sleep Mega
me turns and asks Hannah if she's the
player named angel that they were
looking for and asks also why she saved
him in the first place as Hannah
confirms who she is a mouth suddenly
appears on the side of her face telling
them to cut ask any check so many
questions leaving everyone stunned by a
Yuji who explained is that there is
someone else just like him answering
migami's question Angel then goes to
tell him why he was saved but Hannah
randomly cuts the mouth off obviously
hiding something continuing Angel which
is like the incarnated sorcerer inside
of her if anyone's confused on why I
keep referring to like her as Angel and
Hannah while she explains to us how
exactly her technique Works simply it
negates curse techniques seals and
barriers because of this it allows her
freely to travel between colonies hence
how she was like originally in Tokyo
Colony 2 as they thought the reason that
she even left this colony in the first
place was because her main goal is to
purge all incarnated players and Tokyo 2
was saturated and cursed Spirits as we
like obviously saw in the Last Arc her
reasoning for this is because the
vessels of incarnated players are
usually suppressed and destroyed upon
Incarnation which goes against the laws
of God therefore Angel chose to coexist
with Hannah sitting there making me asks
if she could use a curse technique to
free Gojo to which she affirms it's
possible but first wants something in
return the disgraced or the Fallen one
she promises to the boys that if they
manage to take him down she won't
hesitate to help well let me all tell
you things certainly take an interesting
turn as Yuji is summoned into his or
sakunas in a world right here stepping
forth both loathe each other's side yet
there isn't any missing around this time
as no sukuna the king of curse reveals
himself to be the disgraced one which
lay absolutely flips the series on its
head and let me tell you right now you
ain't ready for what's about to happen
and I I still can't literally fathom
what's just gone down in 213. but
anyways anyways Murphy Ford noticing
that something's up with his boy making
me cools out his name asking if he's
okay looking like he freaking died on
the inside Yuji says that he just ain't
really feeling that well and asks Hannah
to switch places with him so that he can
lie down man's actually suffering after
realizing he's been hunted by yet
another ancient sorcerer having moved
out of Hannah's point of view Yuji then
begins trying to gesture that the
disgraced one is sukuna Man actually
love migami's confused ass face right
here eventually though and after sitting
down with Hannah Hebrew realizes what
Yuji is trying to say making me Ponders
on how they needed help to save Gojo but
now they're completely back at square
one as her Target is technically ug
similarly Yuji Muses about why sakuna
told him to keep quiet and concludes
that angel must have some sort of
ability that can completely obliterate
sakuna without any chance of return Yuji
obviously being Yuji thinks that this is
a cheap price to pay to end the cursed
spirit and decides that as soon as the
others implement the roles required to
save sakumi he will die for the two
comparatively overthinking everything
angel speaks again breaking their
thoughts and remarking that it's odd how
a large number of people are currently
entering the colony quickly the group
command they called game to show the
current culling game player base while
they're revealing 807 active players
with more joining every minute so right
now in this story with Yuji and stuff
we're in November of 2018 well taking
things back quite a few months until
February refunded kinjaku and sakuna
Chef arume are explaining to the US
officials the existence of curse energy
and curse spur
so apparently Chris is a usually only
observable by the Japanese population or
some exceptions this includes the fact
that they are mostly invisible to like
the naked eye obviously curses and curse
energy themselves live within like
specific wavelengths of visible light
that the normal human brain can't pick
up on and man-made cameras don't
actually capture the correct light to
view what's really happening through
their lens watch by the way if you've
watched yellow moth's Dope video going
over Jujutsu kaizen's Iceberg well it
goes into the theory that due to
kaizen's Cursed realm is the same place
as in gigo akatami's first story called
number nine and which the main character
who I think like looks exactly like a
mix of sakuna Gojo and mega me uses
weapons and chikagami-like creatures
that he summons from nine different
boxes that interact with a shadowy realm
plus remember that one time sakuna told
the black box to open just before he
used a flame Arrow to sing jogo to the
cursed realm honestly I just didn't move
on right now otherwise I might just
start dropping series changing theories
that have hid Canon right on the spot so
anyway after having handed out the
cursed glasses udemy lets everyone know
that they function as a screen and will
allow them to see curses along with the
Menifee stations made by Coast energy
and certainly after placing on the
glasses the US president along with his
secretaries react and shock horror
asking what kind of disgusting trick
this is Cyrus one of the U.S president's
officials speaks up telling them that
they all need to calm down as they'd
already been able to confirm that this
is all reality and if they don't cease
this opportunity they'll fall behind as
a global power the two Sorcerers then
exercise the cursed Spirit assuring the
officials that they mean no harm
elaborating some more on how curses
don't appear on man-made cameras Ora May
state that they have video footage
recorded using Jiu Jitsu technology that
works by capturing a puppet's vision
specifically they show footage to the
officials that was taken through
kokichi's puppet's vision giving them a
taste of sukuna Gojo nanami and todo's
abilities the president like who's just
watched all of us makes a joke about it
not being IMAX quality however secretary
stylists are oh my God stylist secretary
Cyrus declares that they just don't get
it cools energy has the potential to
become a clean this energy source and
history replacing every other form of
known energy on the entire planet Cyrus
stresses that even the blonde dude they
just watched through hands possesses
enough curse energy to power an entire
country sitting before them the body
swapping goon then informs him that in
November Tokyo will become a domain of
pure viciousness where all Jiu Jitsu
users will be forced to congregate for a
ritual hearing this and becoming enraged
the president of the good old USA
demands to know if he's being told to
kidnap Japanese citizens and use them as
research subjects standing there himself
Cyrus insists on the importance of
tapping intercourse energy as an
alternative energy source he emphasizes
that Sorcerers defied modern science in
technology because their brains were
wired differently however the whole idea
of abducting people for human
experimentation truly horrifies the
president in an attempt to fully
convince the big p Cyrus goes on a mad
ride citing various Nations like China
Russia Saudi Arabia and the Middle East
who would surpass him as a world power
if they did not do anything
beginning to twist facts it declares
that their operation would be to form a
protection for the Japanese people
against other countries that could
Target them indiscriminately sorcerer or
not his advisor also suspected that
because this negotiation was being kept
under reps the failure to comply would
force kinjaku to negotiate with other
countries having overheard them kinjaku
added that because Sorcerers were a
minority even among Japanese citizens
the November Gathering would be an
excellent opportunity to collect
specimens knowing that they're a
Japanese descendants in the US the
president orders them to be heavily
guarded in order to protect them from
attacks by foreign countries quickly
following this up hitting turns and asks
for Gary K this Special Operations
Commander how many soldiers they should
deploy to Japan Gary who calls himself
like a military man mate bro we
obviously all figure that one out ask
for more confirmation about the average
strength of sorcerers after learning
that the main threat in Gojo would be
locked away in November Gary becomes
confident that one battalion of 60
soldiers would suffice given that all
the sorcerers were amateurs hidden heard
that even with their supernatural
abilities they couldn't compete with his
skill weapons and experience of trained
U.S soldiers kinjaku casually agrees but
States he'd still recommend a full
Battalion of at least 800 soldiers to
deal with his Sorcerers effectively
hearing this Gary dismisses the idea
mocking the Japanese people and pretty
much calling them weak empathy Turk
speaking up odomay proposes a kissed and
moments later kinjaku Snidely guessed
that the 15 men guarding the amazing
room definitely wasn't everyone here so
I always lose it here but the meeting
actually ends in the special ops manager
goes in depth to the president about how
in addition to the 15 Secret Service
agents guarding their room men from Sac
the caa's paramilitary division were
patrolling the White House along with
them there's another 45 elite soldiers
ready to bring down sugaryto having
moved from the East to the west side of
the building now they believe that
ghetto would never be able to defeat all
of them a new West office and wanting to
wrap this up hito gets ready to unleash
his technique in a show of dominance
opposite them on the East Side that
crazy ass man Gary states that these
silly old Japanese people should stick
to anime and cars right now the US
objective isn't to win but to instead
present such an overwhelming show of
force that is America instead though
man's instantly shocked when all of his
soldiers began falling from the sky
oblivious to how it even happened though
after chucking on his sunnies Gary
finally realized the true horrifying
power that is conspirate manipulation
back inside kinjaku throws down all 45
name tags in front of the president
asking if they Now understand so
skipping away from our February like we
were just in and time traveling all the
way up to November and first of all mind
if I like just blow your minds for a
moment here or remember Reiko she wasn't
actually the only one that was a star
plasma vessel like I actually thought
there was only one star plasma vessel
hence why tingham was like nah I guess I
can't anyway she wasn't Yuki was
actually also compatible with tingen but
the reason tenkin chose Rico was because
no one existed with her potential making
her the ideal vessel what's just keeps
me wondering like is Yuji someone who's
compatible with sukuna because he also
fits the same potential as a vessel I
don't know it's just an idea that I've
had while scripting obviously let me
know your thoughts on that down below
when Yuki demanded to know why tingen
hadn't rest not merging with another
vessel The Immortal sorcerer stated that
they had simply accepted reality tinken
knew that it would eventually happen and
he might become a threat to humanity
upon evolving but reason that they could
retain this sanity using barrier
techniques which does make sense as
tingen is the most proficient barrier
user currently known in the series was
sakuna being the greatest RTC user of
all time as well and since by the
explanation Yuki asks a really good 10
question was it reasonable to burden all
of the children with his own
responsibilities like it's honestly just
said that this thumb of a man doesn't
see the star plasma vessel as humans but
more it's just Expendable paces and
that's why Yuki was so paved with how he
casually disregarded them thinking on
the past now Yuki grumbles that she
could have helped the star organization
if the aim was to Simply prevent the
merging instead of killing the Souls as
him revealed that Yuki is able to hear
the voices of past star placement
vessels unlike tinken itself tingin
asked Yuki to tell them what their
voices were saying but Yuki refused
stating that the immortal sorcerer would
only use those words to justify their
decision to evolve sign over not really
getting anywhere Tegan states that they
would have liked to chat some more yet
they're unable to as it's shown that the
megalomaniac body swapping Fame King
jaku was able to break through and enter
the area above the Tomb of the star
Corridor if you all remember from way
back at the beginning of the preparation
Arc well choso had teamed up with Yuki
to protect tengen from this exact issue
due to this choso our brother is the
first and the Sip kinjaku or standing
opposite his disgusting father he staked
his intent to finally end him kinjaku
though simply dismisses him as a
dispensable porn declaring that the
preparations for the merger between
tingen and the Japanese civilian
population had been completed with a
culling game having now served its true
purpose he then also States that once he
gets his hands on tingen it's all over
Japan and the world are done for
suddenly we then move into a theater as
kinjaku shows his son one version of
what could possibly happen later on if
everyone remembers during Shibuya and
how Yuki mentioned that optimizing
cursed energy through tenkin will cause
non-sorcerers to assimilate well kinjaku
adds onto this theory of who's here
revealing that he believed that to be
the step which preceded the merger and
unlike Yuki he didn't want to create a
world without cursed Spirits kinchaku
wanted to cause curse Spurs to evolve to
the next stage to create a new form of
cursed energy so in order to achieve
this he began citing his earlier
experimentations including the creation
of the death painting wombs but deemed
them all to be utter failures we all
know from stuff that we've learned so
far that an evolved tengan is more
curspeed than human so merging all
non-sorcerer is with him would cause the
Consciousness to technically cause
tingen's Consciousness to become one
with everyone in Japan this means in
King jaku's eyes that a hundred million
or so people merging together would be
able to create a god-level monolith with
infinite power with kinjaku's film
coming to a close and the realm changing
back to normal choso just asks why why
is he even doing this touch the craziest
sorcerer alive stated that it just
sounded like fun with kinjaku trying to
drop a joke an infuriated chozo claps
his hands together before beginning an
attack with piercing blood although you
know typical gear fashion we don't
actually get to see that piercing blood
attack straight away instead we go back
to before the fight kicked off but now
with big bro choso in the room as well
there he tells yukin tingen that he'd
like to face kinjaku alone Yuki though
stated that he'll die if he did so to
watch choso like the absolute G he is
counted by asking if she would prefer to
fight kinshaku alongside him he admitted
that in such a situation he would only
be a hinderens so their best bet was for
him to engage kinjaju in combat and
force him to reveal more about his
cursed techniques giving Yuki and tenkin
an advantage Yuki states that he'll
still die but chosu stated that it
didn't matter if it allowed themed in
his and his brother's manipulative
father flashing back as chosu's piercing
blood shoots off hinjaku watching the
approaching Tech manages to easily Dodge
out of the way of the attack while
releasing a centipede-like curse to
attack his opponent having destroyed the
curse along with a large section of the
Tome choso watches kinjaku shoot out in
front of him and fling a large piece of
rubble and his direct chin seeing it
chosu screams that he's been
underestimated but instantly he's proven
wrong as several curse Birds burst out
from behind the throne piece of concrete
thrown a condensed orb of blood forward
himself choto uses Supernova to
eviscerate the cursors however the cloud
provided kinjaku with a quick opening to
engage the death painting and
hand-to-hand combats after being pushed
back and realizing that he was at a
disadvantage so as we tried to buy some
time by asking how kinjaku intended to
use Yuji since he was undeniably
different from the death paintings so
obviously it's explained here by kinjaku
that he doesn't really have a plan for
Yuji other than being sakuna's vessel
Yuji and sakuna are catalysts as long as
they told live the chain of curse
enraged by his opponent's conviction
that joji was the reason for all of this
Bloodshed declares that it was kinjaku
whose existence fueled the chain of
curses not his brothers being taken off
guard total looked down to see some
small curses tugging at him when all of
a sudden kinjaku takes the opportunity
and pummels his face sending him
spinning backwards and suddenly
following up he Stomps our poor boy's
face and condescendently declares that
he's only been using low-level curses on
him but maybe that was unnecessary since
choso was so pathetically weak just
straight up and rage now chosu grabs
kinjaku's foot again but he gets nowhere
as he's quickly slammed back against the
floor kinjaku asks the defending cursed
womb if he even knows what the rank of
special grade stands for which also
unable to block any longer because
overrides and completely decimates him
all the while this body swapping freak
remarks there is the ability to
single-handedly destroy Nations those
like Saturday and suguru with special
grades because of the obvious ability
abilities to completely obliterate
Nations or create an army of
unparalleled monsters hinjaku added that
by strengthening pathetically weak
curses with curse energy he can easily
deal with a failure like choso playing
there a boy berates himself for failing
to be a good older brother to Yuji and
his other siblings he needed to protect
them and be there to be dependent on as
that's what big brothers do but now he
couldn't even Land one hit against his
creep of a father man will never go down
and still like the king he is chozo
stands back up refusing to evaluate his
brother's names be disrespected
screaming he demands all his brothers
lend him their strength as he prepares
to deliver a raging attack from behind
him choso all of a sudden begins to feel
the support of his younger brothers
pushing him forward ESO kachizu and Yuji
assure him that he's got this
subsequently an emotionally overwhelmed
choso begins attacking hinjaku using all
his power and cursed technique standing
there the letter observes that the
pissing blood's initial velocity is its
top speed dodging the attack he
continues explaining that the ability
loses its lethality once the opponent
gets used to its speed and changing the
trajectory will only slow it down
watching pinjaku effortlessly Dodges
attacks Tricia decides to further use an
approximation of one king the most
powerful version of Esau's rot technique
which if you've forgotten what this
technique does well when the lines of
blood connect with its Target they are
instantly burned by the corrosive
effects of the death penis blood as
chosu dots and throwing a fat right Hawk
hinjaka causes version of eso's
technique just a cheap substitute
however tosu releases the technique
sending four beams of blood shooting
towards the body swapping Fame having
summoned a curse hinjaku backflips out
of the way using the curse as a shield
before sending a bunch of low-level
curses towards chosu as well having been
hit directly back in jagu's previous
attack the letter explains that easel's
ability was not as fast as pissing blood
and wouldn't even affect him as he's his
father chilling over on a tree branch
now he asks the cursed womb if there was
even a point to everything that he's
doing now beaten and bruised chosen it
clears then he must fight with the grace
of eso the freedom of kachizu and the
domineering strength of Yuji suddenly
kinjaku was taken off guard when chosu's
arm fully detaches and begins blasting
towards his enemy using the connecting
blood as a role using this arm is a
freaking grappling hook chosu lectures
on and pulls the megalomaniac sorcerer
towards him destroying the ground in the
process before reconnecting his hand to
his body and utterly pummeling his fat
right hook into the face of kinjaku
still like my man's way too quick
somehow big brain kinjaku managed to use
a curse shield to protect himself and
lie on their unharmed he asks if his son
is done choso would just hit the fattest
grin on his face like like man's entire
purpose has been for this moment right
here asks the dumbass what he thinks
releasing another burst of iso's ability
he does his best to attack the fleeing
Sorcerer And if you just didn't catch on
to what he's doing right now our bro big
freaking choso is actually Omega third
eye level of pre-planning and uses his
brother's technique to create a funnel
to purposely trap hinjaku within giving
him utterly no nowhere to run as he
releases a few supernovas on either side
of the malevolent entity instantly as
Supernova activates something destroys
the entire floor all around kijaku only
leaving a precise place where kinjaku
was standing intact kind of confused
chozo Ponders if immersed but just knows
that he didn't he activated simultaneous
attacks all around him so how could it
be due to this he quickly deduces that
he was finally able to get him to use
something other than cursed Spirit
manipulation finally revealing herself
as well this special grade sorcerer Yuki
sumoku states that she may have been an
only child but thanks chosu either way
as your older brother for all of his
efforts having heard what Yugi has to
say trust me faints as relief hits him
and falls through a gap that appears in
the barrier looking at her opponent Yuki
states that she likes it wrath but will
have to beat him into shape so as I said
just before Yuki is a special grade
sorcerer yet even kenjaku reveals that
because of the security around her
technique he was unable to acquire any
information on her unwilling to face a
close range attack from an unknown
technique King Jaco decides to maintain
a safe distance and summons the curse
spirit that he had used at the White
House this cool Spirit here like I think
everyone presumed isn't even originally
from Japan still it's actually a special
Great Divine Bane which uses a technique
that removes obstacles by using Concepts
or logic against cursed technique
targets more or less it's freaking
broken Yuki who's like obviously
interested to see how strong this Bane
is begins darting forward while raping
up a shikagami called gruda into a ball
dropping a shikagami down towards your
feet you're hitting boots it with all of
her mind sending it blasting towards the
Divine curse From Below kinjaku
completely blown away can only watch as
his special grade as utterly annihilated
with a single blow quickly following up
Yuki taunts him for being cautious
against an unknown technique before
revealing her ability revolves around
the idea of mass which like we all
learned in school Mass is the true
weight of something and to figure out
something's mess all we got to do is
divide mass by gravity so 30 kgs times
9.8 meters second squared equals 294
Newtons but I don't even know if that
actually matters to the story here I
just thought I'd Chuck that in because
why not ferociously she punches kinjaku
in the face sending him shooting back
across the room in fact the blow is so
damn strong and not only rips off both
of his arms but also since I'm flying
across the empty space within tengen's
barrier utterly pulverizing any
generated structure in his path it's
actually shown that kinjaku was hit so
far that he completely exited the
confines of the barrier itself sitting
there kinjaku realizes that Yuki uses a
specific concept to Target acoustic nay
creating mass overwhelming enough to
obliterate anything in its path Yuki
standing there and just looking like a
babe explained that she can give herself
any amount of virtual or imaginary mass
and that she calls that technique star
rage having heard this information
kingjaku also deduces that virtual mass
imbued by star rage doesn't actually
affect Yuki as your speed hasn't
decreased at all something super
different about Yuki is the fact that
she also defies Concepts meaning that
kinjaku is completely unable to use a
high grade curse Spirit like he had in
Shibuya looking at her the body swapping
douche wonders if you really can take
down this Beast of a sorcerer
recognizing that kinjaku's previous
ability involved gravity and leaves you
he convinced that kingjaku has at least
three other techniques beside Guido's
curse manipulation and body hopping
technique he doubts that he has many
more as well as without an external Aid
like Yuda arakatsu's Rika the user's
brain would explode under such stress
she guessed that in the worst case
scenario kinjaku has yet another full
technique upper sleeve thinking as well
kinjaku deduces that yohi's special
grade rank suggests that she probably
has a high curse energy output extension
technique what she'll use as your trump
card Yuki's plan here though is that
she's actually going to force kinjaku to
use his domain expansion which as we've
learned so far throughout the series
will make it more difficult for him to
use multiple curse techniques afterwards
in the end she decides to systematically
weaken kingjaku's domain before striking
the final blow but that isn't actually
what's going to happen if you think
alki's plans ever worked out and should
use a Kaizen you are smoking on the
wrong pack this is kinjaku's world man
has the plan planned out all right like
you guys need to get down in your mind
nothing goes anyone's way in the series
he knows that they find each other
tricky but unlike Yuki he doesn't like
the confidence to unleash pure dominance
having moved his hands together kinjaku
releases his domain expansion the
burialis womb profusion instantly Yuki
screams out to Tinker wondering if
there's still enough time so good old uh
good old yeah again taking things back a
moment tingen explained that during the
battle they would confront kenjaku in a
labyrinth thing Barrier located directly
below the cursed warehouse and just
above the Tomb of the star Corridor each
romance out of the celebrant themed
barrier is empty this allows a skilled
sorcerer for say like this example
kinjaku to be able to alter its
structure or at least that's what they
would want him to think as if that's the
case then he'll most likely feel
comfortable and lower his guard the
reason they need him to feel comfortable
is so that he'll nonchalantly use the
domain expansion within tenkin's empty
area and if this is the case tinken
who's extremely proficient at barrier
control but obviously from what we've
seen but under the condition that you
can hold off conjunction for 10 seconds
be able to manipulate and dispel the
theme's domain so obviously Yuki could
have also used a domain expansion here
but using it during that time would also
cause her domain to be dispelled as
that's literally their plan here with
tingen instead to protect herself from
tingen she had planned to use a simple
domain Yuki pondered a fusing her domain
would be a more efficient way of forcing
their opponent to open his domain
however tingen reason that her domain
would be dispelled first as it's
technically the outer layer and might
also give kinjaku the opportunity to
counter with a simple domain or Hollow
wicker basket lastly he warned her that
kinjaku is one of the very few people
who can equal him and barrier usage so
don't assume that his domain is like
everyone else's which was the biggest
foreshadowing to what we've just
freaking seen yet kinjaku's true
potential was even higher than tingen
ever suspected as just like the goat
during Shibuya these body swapping Genie
cast a burialis domain leaving no outer
boundary for tinken to remove at all
instantly in retaliation to The Domain
you could cast to a new Shadow style
simple domain however almost immediately
and Judy kingjaku not having a barrier
on his domain tingen's technique
actually began stripping away Yuki's
shell with no other option she Sprints
forth in an attempt to take kinjaku down
slowly tenkin also began stripping away
the body swapper's structuralist barrier
however kinshaku remained unfazed and
screamed that unlike tingen he has lived
for over a thousand years and a cursed
world of Rife with conflicts and
alliances then out of freaking nowhere
Yuki who's left with no defenses is
utterly rocked by the pure force that
his gravity pounding down on her singing
or shooting through the floor of Tegan's
empty labyrinthine barrier now in the
Tomb of the star Corridor itself and
with Yuki completely and utterly crushed
kinshaku staked they had this special
great sorcerer used her domain instead
of relying on an old fool she may have
feared better man this old dude must
have no friends because holy he just
loves talking to himself he even threw
the Box on that tingaku had hidden a
vital piece of information regarding the
culling bro can't even finish his
sentence as he notices Yuki shikagami
still hasn't disappeared instantly
shooting at him guruda destroys the area
around kinjaku forcing him back kinjaku
guess that his sorcerer was trying to
buy herself enough time to heal using
RTC however man is just completely wrong
and Yuki looking like she just got out
of a washing machine after 24 hours
still somehow continues to relentlessly
attack disregarding her injuries and
giving the villain no chance to recover
kinjaku just blown away asks why she
isn't healing but Yuki just utterly
doesn't care continuing like the pure
demon she is Yuki lashes out and kicks
the ancient sorcerer until it seemed as
if she may have finally reached her
limit dropping to the floor saying this
kinjaku asked her if that was it leading
Yuki to ask the villain if he had
forgotten her declaration she likes it
wrath they're right on freaking Q the
big man himself chosu returns to the
fight entering the empty barrier from
behind kinjaku with its technique fully
activated doing the Giga as per usual
though we skip back just before the
battle broke out this is if any reason
that domains neutralize curse techniques
so he wouldn't open his domain if he
expected choso to join the fight later
meaning that he should as he mention
before fight first he suggested that a
face off against the madman first
following him into believing that his
only opponent for the rest of the fight
was Yuki then finally reappear back in
the battle now and completely stunned
kinjaku is immediately restrained by
Garuda laying him down firmly landed on
the ground chosu slaps his hands
together and tells his brothers to watch
as their big bro is about to commit
Pedro's side incidentally our boy uses
pissing blood on his dad at a
point-blank range yeah bro how did your
brain even managed to dodge there Yuki
and choso are also just like blown away
as they get a glimpse of kinjaku's True
Form Yuki observed that the villain had
spun his head deliberately to deflect
the attack which is just actually insane
when you think about it man's got like a
his skull is literally just a cap at
this moment like he's wearing it around
around like Chuck like it's crazy I mean
interchange caps change hairstyles and
stuff is what I'm wondering right up
anyway I need a I need to continue on
she concluded that can Jackal was
desperate enough to do such a move
because he was also becoming troubled
knowing this the duo keep up the hated
bait down attacking in tandem Lane fat
kicks punches and elbows on the sorcerer
using her RTC Yuki easily manages to fix
her mangled arm and other injuries but
the momentary distraction we can start
rage just enough to allow King jacket to
escape welding Garuda like a whip now
Yuki swings at kinjaku only just missing
but the energy released from the attack
as early demolishes the floor and walls
of the star Corridor around them with
everyone falling down onto some water
below shotsu takes the opportunity to
attack through the smoke screen while
simultaneously Yuki likes loose another
attack using a star rage and viewed
cursed Hall caught off guard themselves
though ochroso and Garuda drop to the
floor under the weight of kinjaku's
overwhelming gravity and replenished
technique Yuki shikigami lashes out
trying to move but it's unable under the
gravity and while Yuki runs intercollect
it she did produces how kinjaku's
technique Works she concludes that the
ancient sorcerer's attacks have a radius
of two or three meters and remained
active for at least six seconds swinging
hookah root at him she knows that once
he's caught something within his gravity
trap Ninjago will then finish it off
with a curse Spirit but doubt that that
will even work against her and she's not
gonna stop until she baits him down and
wins though she should have honestly
just won and not internalized her as
ginjaku was able to Parry off a vicious
head punch before grabbing Yuki's arm
and directing a miniature Uzumaki at her
face with Yuki completely fried from the
point-blank blast she begins to Dart
backwards when all of a sudden kinjaku
follows up and forms another miniature
Uzumaki while remarking that her density
may have increased due to Star rage but
her tensile strength didn't releasing
the ability kinjaku leads choto
screaming in horror as the attack tears
straight through Yuki's abdomen really
damn abruptly regained fly into a
flashback where our team is sitting at a
bar there Yuki asked choso if he didn't
want to be there for Yuji since it
seemed like he was throwing his life
away now no answering the question
though Charles you asked if he's even
human who remembers thinking back to the
time when his brothers took form and
realized that they would never be
accepted by humans because of their
deformed locks so from this supposed to
decided to live as a curse with his
brothers hence why he killed so many
people in Shibuya and why now he burdens
themselves with their deaths said him
with his choices big bro choto states
that if he had chosen to live as a human
he wouldn't have lost them weeping he
wonders why chose the easy path was it
because he didn't want to see his
brother suffering as humans however a
human then showed up who just happened
to be suffering himself those four were
meant to be brothers and fight together
as one but instead he took the easy Road
and left Yuji all alone returning to the
battle choso getting up to unleash a
spinning wheel of blood at the enemy
states that the only way to make it up
to all of his brothers is to use up all
of his life here but before he could
even do that the G himself like this is
the only time I'm calling Tegan a g
because I don't know his ulterior
motives right here the G removes them
forcibly from the barrier Yuki looking
like Gojo for real tells him that this
battlefield was where the death
painting's Life as a curse ended and his
time as a human begun so because of that
he must love above the falling choso
Yuki's body also falls to the ground but
in two pieces whether seemingly defeated
by kinjaku's previous blow behind the
two tingen then reveals themselves
causing kinjaku to actually start
laughing at the thumb's appearance even
comparing him to sukuna's original form
which actually has to have some kind of
freaking mirror in the story right there
tingen is like dude check your kills all
I had to do was distract you for
literally two damn seconds allowing
Yuki's top half the I don't understand
this as well you his top half she just
reaches out and grabs his leg to
literally reach out and grab your cankle
bro not taking him seriously though
kinjaku just tells her to die before all
of a sudden and out of freaking nowhere
a massive Force begins ripping the
sorcerer down towards Yuki as I
mentioned at some point earlier on you
techniques alteration and mass doesn't
actually affect her up to a certain
density that is and removing kinjaku
asked choso what makes a special grade
well nothing you've seen so far from
Yuki would actually give out girl the
ranking of special grade but yeah she's
insane her strength alone is mental but
this next technique is what makes her
the threat to every freaking life form
on this planet when yuhi goes beyond her
Max density control point this sorcerer
can add an infinite amount of mass with
her curse technique and if you somehow
haven't caught on yet yes she can create
a goddamn Black Hole by just
continuously just pushing more and more
density into it the end result of what
she had just formed was the creation of
a black hole which not only consumed
Yuki's entire body but trapped all
matter and even light within earth right
before disappearing you hear the clear
to kinjaku that he should have seen this
coming as gravity mass and time or need
to be wielded with Extreme Caution with
the black hole fully formed it begins
sucking away literally everything from
the surrounding area inside of the home
of the star Corridor as the energy from
the black hole then finally begins to
subside it's revealed that even the
ceiling of the Tomb again crumbling away
with natural light breaking through and
lighting up the underground Chambers by
the way you know I'm just going to say
this right here wrist and peace Yuki I'm
pretty sure she died from there so rest
in peace what an insane attack but
despite the immense gravitational force
exerted by the black hole kinjaku
somehow manages to survive climbing out
from underneath the collapsed deer
Breeze stunned by this himself Tegan
asked if he had used the reverse curse
technique in combination with his
gravity technique but kinjaku actually
makes a shocking Revelation declaring
that the true nature of the technique
had not been gravity at all he admitted
that his third curse technique
originally belonged to yuji's mother
kaori itadori with its true form being
the anti-gravitational system kinjaku
added that he had taken a risky Gamble
and used laps to reverse the effects of
the technique stabilizing the output and
activation by using his own body as a
domain like I said this is like
obviously Kim who's freaking world man
has pre-planned absolutely everything
for a millennia so I don't know how our
boys are going to actually end up
wanting here like the famous jjk scholar
broken Ronin also once said every word
in the series has Merit so think on this
kinjaku as he watches tingen's operation
disappearing states that this was just a
warm-up then finding the letters body
encased within the trunk of a tree in
the star Corridor kinjaku says goodbye
to his friend
and I'm just sitting here like hmm
thinking on those words what exactly do
you mean by that what were you friends
back in the day I know he's a little bit
older than you were but were your
friends back in the day what is kinjaku
to tingen plus everything all of the
relations that happened in this art like
are actually mind-boggling we get to see
sakuna had four eyes and why did kinjaku
specifically bring up the relation
between like how tingen looked and
sakona quite interesting so it's crazy I
feel like the whole culling game right
now is just utterly mind-boggling either
way I hope you have enjoyed the video
and if you want more stuff just like
this but for a variety of different
series then let me know down below plus
leave a like push this video so a fat 5K
likes and I'll try to do a backflip or
something I definitely can't do that but
till then now it's been a professional
did you know at diavolo and LC wall Inn
8-bit bye